[Music]
here in this video we will discuss the
long-awaited trailer of season 4 of
stranger things in it we saw 11 and all
the others from hawkins at least the
ones who survived they have all gone
their own separate ways thinking that
they have defeated the mind player and
normality has returned
but it was just the calm before the
storm
of course this video will be mainly on
the new monsters that were revealed to
us as well as the remaining demogorgon
and maybe the upside down bats but we
will also give a short recap first just
a minute at the most on what the trailer
is all about
so let's get to it
so let's start with a short recap of the
trailer before discussing the monsters
well it starts with a strange sinister
voice saying you have broken everything
your suffering is almost at an end
ending with a scene of an evil looking
clock with a pendulum and a terrifying
demonic monster awaking
later in the trailer we see the kids
from hawkins are now more grown up being
in high school and all
some have gone their own separate ways
after the events of season 3. eleven is
in california and seems to have lost her
powers or maybe they are just dormant
for the time being the others have been
relocated away from hawkins for their
safety
the trailer continues with the
government pleading for
11 to help against the war with the
upside down then we go to a swarm of
bat-like creatures that are seen
swarming over an abandoned house in the
meantime jim hopper is a whirlway now a
prisoner of the soviet union and along
with others in the prison are tested
against a captured white demogorgon the
trailer shows more scenes of the kids
and the haunted house and them battling
the flying creatures as well as entering
the upside down dimension and it all
ends with a demonic creature stating
that they have lost as he comes down
from the ground suspended in the air by
tentacles or tendrils emerging from his
back
so let's discuss the creatures seen in a
trailer shall we well firstly before
discussing the big baddy of the show we
shall take a quick look at the white
demogorgon and the upside down flying
creatures as we know demogorgon is a
tall thin humanoid creature with
elongated limbs its head seems to lack
facial features until it unfolds the
flesh like a flower to reveal the petals
lined with sharp teeth many of them and
a large open mouth the derma gorgon was
a captured specimen taken captive by the
russians in their own experiments of the
interdimensional gateway or a rift it
seems to be like all the other
demogorgons and hence not an important
antagonist in the season
secondly we saw a swarm of flying
creatures at first one might think that
they are bats but if we take a closer
look we can see them having several
tails and thicker wings in a way closely
resembling those soul-eater monsters
from the movie shang-chi and the legend
of the ten rings in fact to a layman
they would be identical in looks they
also happen to be in swarms of hundreds
as well as serving a sinister villain
these creatures if i'm not mistaken are
the vag will which are deformed
creatures with bat like wings and
tendrils growing from their head
and they are creatures that swarm the
nether regions of dungeons and dragons
flying around in darkness to search for
victims and since this series is very
influenced by dnd i'm willing to bet
that these will be the stranger things
versions of the vargril
so now let's take a look at what we have
been delaying the new monster let's
theorize on its origins its powers its
revelation and design
okay so right from the start this
monster is scary as [ __ ] he gives off
the spin head slash freddy krueger
lucifer vibe around him even though we
know almost absolutely nothing about him
we can say from the words that he
uttered in a trailer that he is the true
ruler or demonic tyrant of the upside
down
all the other demogorgons the bat
vagwills and even the mind player might
be under his control
pitchers definite wolf and the
parademons of justice league under his
control in the justice league movie he
might be a powerful character and
seemingly a boss but he still is just a
herald to a more sinister more powerful
being that is dark side so the same
could be inferred to the mind player
being a gigantic monster herald to this
terrifying demon
so the way it was revealed was just
awesome the way he awoke and opened his
eyes was exactly like a cinematic
trailer of the lich king from warcraft
and he has his blue dead eyes like the
night king from game of thrones his body
design is humanoid but with the lack of
epidermal skin
he looks to be human size but maybe a
bit bigger than an average man
his head is bald and skullish in
appearance having a similar look to the
newborn xenomorph of alien resurrection
his entire body looks to be mutant like
with tendrils and tentacles growing out
of it it looks fleshy but with a heart
and amorphous cancerous looking muscle
fibers
he also has sharp claws on his hands
like reptilian in nature but the
creepiest thing about this monster is
the fact that he has several generals
slash tentacles growing from his back
and that they keep him suspended in
midair
his powers might be near all powerful in
his own home dimension as we can see the
characters are struggling really
struggling inside the upside down and
things just seem to be floating and
being thrown about easily i would say
that he would have telephonic abilities
telekinetic powers and even extreme
durability and stamina
so is this monster the real mind flayer
of stranger things
is a giant monster from season 2 and 3
actually an avatar of him functioning as
a vessel of his will and power when he
slumbers
seems very likely now that when we think
about it but we'll only know more when
the next trailer drops in and the show
finally airs on netflix
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam